[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend die werbereise des
Kanzlers im globalen Süden geht weiter
das Verhältnis zu Ländern dort soll
besser werden deren und insbesondere die
deutsche Abhängigkeit von Russland China
und Co verringert werden und so war nach
Senegal mega Südafrika Vietnam
Indonesien Argentinien Chile und
Brasilien heute nun Indien an der Reihe
doch einfach ist es für Scholz nicht den
Subkontinent als Handelspartner zu
überzeugen das liegt auch an
indienshaltung in Bezug auf Russlands
Krieg indien hat seine Gründe warum es
sich gegenüber Putin neutral verhält und
den Einmarsch der Russen nicht
verurteilt und so ist Scholz Strategie
Schwenk in der Außenpolitik einer der
etwas ruckelt
nach der Ankunft in Delhi begegnet Olaf
Scholz heute zunächst mal Olaf Scholz
der Kanzler in der Ferne großzügiger
plakatiert als zu Hause für das perfekte
willkommen wäre Staub auf dem roten
Teppich schlecht auf höchster
diplomatischer Ebene fast so schlecht
wie Sand im Getriebe dafür sollte heute
kein Platz sein denn als Olaf Scholz
dann narrendramodi begegnet stehen alle
Zeichen auf Freundschaft zwischen den
Ländern und ihren Lenkern der Kanzler
setzt den Thron dann auch betont
optimistisch
wir haben bereits sehr gute Beziehungen
und wollen Sie jetzt noch weiter
intensiv ausbauen
unter dieser Prämisse ist es nicht
schwierig gemeinsame Pläne zu schmieden
Ausbau der Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
Zusammenarbeit in der Forschung
Austausch von Fachkräften läuft nur an
anderer Stelle steht was im Weg
indien hat Russland für seinen Krieg
nicht öffentlich verurteilt und das ist
ein Streitpunkt zwischen Indien und
Europa zwischen Indien und Deutschland
der Grund dafür indien will den
Gesprächsfaden zu Russland nicht
abreißen lassen denn in denen ist
abhängig von russischen Rüstungsgütern
55% aller indischen Waffen kommen aus
Russland Indien fühlt sich von vielen
Seiten bedroht deshalb ist die
Wunschliste lang Flugzeuge Raketen
Panzer Moskau liefert seit Jahrzehnten
was Indiens Armee begehrt und erntet
dafür jetzt offenbar Indiens Neutralität
unsere Beziehungen zu Moskau wurden
ausgebaut zu einer Zeit in der westliche
Demokratie die feindliche
Militärdiktatur in Pakistan aufgerüstet
haben aber keine Waffen an Indien
liefern wollten wir sollten diesen Teil
der Geschichte nicht vergessen
da ist der wunde Punkt diplomatische
Übung für Gast und Gastgeber heute also
unterschiedliche Perspektiven so
verpacken dass die Stimmung nicht
eintrübt wir wissen dass dieser Krieg
mit einem Prinzip bricht auf das wir
alle gemeinsam uns lange verständigt
haben und dass wir miteinander teilen
dass man nämlich nicht mit Gewalt
Grenzen verschiebt seit Beginn der
Entwicklungen in der Ukraine hat Indien
betont das Streit durch Dialog und
Diplomatie gelöst werden muss Indien ist
bereit Friedensinitiativen zu
unterstützen
Wege ebnen vielleicht das wichtigste
Ziel dieser Reise so sei heute auch über
Rüstungsgeschäfte gesprochen worden
deutsche Waffentechnik für Indien wenn
das die Abhängigkeiten von Russland
abbaut wäre es mehr als ein Geschäft
zwei Amtszeiten ist tonusmäßig Schluss
für den Präsidenten von Nigeria und so
sucht das Land heute nicht nur ein neues
Parlament sondern auch einen neuen
Präsidenten mit seinen ca 220 Millionen
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohnern ist
Nigeria die größte Volkswirtschaft
Afrikas die Hauptstadt Abuja liegt in
zentralen Nigeria also zwischen dem
muslimisch dominierten Norden und dem
christlich dominierten Süden seit dem
Ende der Militärherrschaft 1999 stritten
sich bisher im Grunde immer zwei um das
Präsidentenamt jemand aus der
regierenden Partei und jemand aus der
größten
Oppositionspartei doch dieses Mal könnte
es einen lachenden Dritten geben gerade
die Jugend eine große Wählergruppe will
raus aus Armut aus Perspektivlosigkeit
und sieht in dem
vergleichsweise jungen Außenseiter ihren
Ausweg Susann von Lojewski
warten das gehört für die Menschen in
Nigeria seit Wochen zum Alltag sie
warten auf Benzin stundenlang das Land
hat Erdölvorkommen ein
Milliardengeschäft das Öl aber wird ins
Ausland exportiert sie warten vor
Geldautomaten neue Banknoten wurden
eingeführt viel zu wenige aber gedruckt
das Leben in Nigeria ist mühsam
es ist nicht einfach viele Leute
beschweren sich um Essen zu kaufen
brauchst du Bargeld du kannst nicht
überweisen viele haben kein Konto das
trifft uns wirklich
ich habe vier fünf Wochen versucht Geld
abzuheben heute habe ich es hier
bekommen
lange Schlangen heute auch vor den
Wahllokalen über 93 Millionen Menschen
haben sich registrieren lassen ein
Rekordwert alles soll besser werden mit
einem neuen Präsidenten und eher gilt
als Geheimfavorit Peter Obi 61 Jahre alt
Unternehmer der Christ ist nicht in den
großen Parteien verhaftet und für viele
ein Hoffnungsträger
es ist eine enorm wichtige Wahl das Land
geht durch eine sehr schwierige Zeit und
es braucht einen dringenden und
sofortigen Neuanfang
Obis gegen Kandidaten kommen aus dem
politischen Establishment sie gelten als
höchst korrupt artigu abubacar und bola
tinobo sind beide über 70 Jahre alt und
Milliardäre beide sind wie der jetzige
Präsident Muslime eigentlich wechseln
sich im Vielvölkerstaat Nigeria Christen
und Muslime an der Staatsspitze ab ob
das auf dieses Mal gilt ungewiss
drei Viertel der Wähler sind unter 49
Jahre alt ihre Stimmen sind entscheidend
wir wollen den Status Quo nicht mehr wir
wollen etwas anderes wir wollen den
Wechseln unter den drei großen
Kandidaten auf dem Wahlzettel bin ich
für Peter Obi
aber fehlt es vor allem auf dem Land an
politische Unterstützung wer immer die
Wahl gewinnt wird es schwer haben die
gewaltigen Probleme Nigerias zu lösen
nahezu täglich gibt es Überfälle und
Terroranschläge auch durch die
islamistische BOKU haram
die Politikwissenschaftlerin idajat
Hassan fürchtet dass die Menschen in
Nigeria den Glauben an die Demokratie
verlieren könnten
sehr ungeduldig sie wollen ein
sofortigen Wandel sobald der Amtseid von
der neuen Verwaltung geschworen wurde
bisher verlaufen die Wahlen weitgehend
friedlich sollte das so bleiben hätte
das eine enorme Symbolkraft für die
gesamte Stabilität im Westen Afrikas
und damit kommen wir zu den Nachrichten
und die beginnen mit einer umstrittenen
Friedensdemo Hannah ja an der Kundgebung
von Linken Politikerin Wagenknecht und
Frauenrechtlerinnen schwarzer haben laut
Polizei rund 13.000 Menschen
teilgenommen bei der Demo vor dem
Brandenburger Tor forderten sie unter
anderem einen sofortigen Stopp der
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine und die
Aufnahme von Friedensverhandlungen die
Initiative von Wagenknecht und schwarzer
wird neben inhaltlichen Punkten auch
wegen einer fehlenden klaren
Abgrenzungen nach rechts kritisiert an
der Kundgebung heute nahmen auch Rechte
Gruppierung teil
die SPD bleibt bei der Berliner
Wiederholungswahl offenbar auf Platz
zwei hinter der CDU allerdings soll sich
der Vorsprung zu den Grünen auf nur 53
Stimmen verkleinert haben das berichten
mehrere Medien und berufen sich dabei
auf Unterlagen des Landeswahlausschusses
am kommenden Montag soll das amtliche
Endergebnis der Wahl zum
Abgeordnetenhaus offiziell verkündet
werden
in der Türkei sind nach dem verheerenden
Erdbeben mittlerweile 184 Personen
festgenommen worden weil ihnen Pfusch am
Bau vorgeworfen wird oder aber weil
Bauvorschriften nicht kontrolliert
worden sein sollen rund
173.000 Gebäude sind bei dem Beben vor
mehr als zwei Wochen eingestürzt oder
schwer beschädigt worden die Zahl der
Toten in der Türkei und in Syrien liegt
laut neuen Behördenangaben mittlerweile
bei mehr als 50.000
bei der Nordischen Ski-WM im
slowenischen Planica gab es heute gleich
viel Medaillen für deutschen Athletinnen
und Athleten vor allem bei den
Skispringerinnen war der Jubel groß im
Teamwettbewerb holten Katharina Althaus
Anna Ruprecht Selina Freitag und Luisa
Görlich WM Gold auf Platz zwei und drei
landeten Österreich und Norwegen im
Einzelspringen der Männer von der
Normalschanze gewannen dann Andreas
Wellinger und Karl Geiger überraschend
Silber und Bronze Weltmeister wurde der
Pole piotre Gila und auch Kombinierer
Julian Schmid holte eine Medaille in
seinem ersten WM-Rennen überhaupt gewann
er Silber hinter Norwegen
die Berlinale versteht sich seit jeher
als politisches Filmfestival
wahrscheinlich hat das aber noch nie
jemand so deutlich gemacht quasi schwarz
auf weiß wie Jurymitglied radu.de bei
seinem Eintrag ins Gästebuch der Stadt
also in Berlin gestern eine klare
Aussage des rumänischen Filmregisseurs
wie klar und eindeutig das Votum der
Jury bei der Vergabe der Bären war das
wissen wir natürlich nicht aber sie
haben sich definitiv geeinigt denn heute
wurden sie verliehen zum 73 mal
Henriette de Maizière und Stefanie Hein
leicht haben sie es nicht gehabt die
Jury mit Präsidentin Christen Stewart an
der Spitze hatte 19 Filme zu bewerten
sehr unterschiedliche aber sagt die
Chefin der Truppe es war lehrreich
es fühlt sich an als hätten wir in den
zwei Wochen mehrere Monate erlebt und
das Resultat überrascht durchaus der
goldene Bär geht an den einzigen
Dokumentarfilm im Wettbewerb zu
Nicola filibär gewinnt mit Sir lademont
auf der Adamo den Hauptpreis die Adamo
ist ein Schiff in Paris eine Tagesklinik
für Menschen mit psychischen Problemen
[Musik]
niemand ist Perfekt sinkt der Mann am
Klavier der Film kommt den Menschen ganz
nah und schaut voller Wärme nicht auf
das Problem sondern auf die
Möglichkeiten
seid ihr verrückt
umzudrehen dass wir von den sogenannten
verrückten immer haben wenn wir uns
schon nicht mit ihnen identifizieren
dann doch anzuerkennen was uns trotz
unserer Unterschiede verbindet
und plötzlich Verwirrung der Zettel ist
weg
aber wo ist nur der Text dazu dann der
silberne Bär für die beste Nebenrolle
spielt Leni Transfrau mit
gefängniserfahrung und Dealer
Vergangenheit
mit einem verdeckten Ermittler soll Leni
einen Drogenhändler überführen der Ehre
selbst Transfrau sieht sich mit dem
Bären auch als Aktivistin geehrt man
muss immer eine Stimme sein und immer
eine Stimme geben und für mich ist
dieser Welt diese Stimme ein Höhepunkt
die erst achtjährige Sophia Otero
gewinnt einen silbernen Bären die
jüngste Preisträgerin die es bei der
Berlinale je gab in 20.000 Arten von
Bienen spielt sie die Hauptrolle ein
Kind das auf der Suche nach seiner
geschlechtlichen Identität ist Sophia
Otero spielt das Kind ganz natürlich und
anrührend
und bedankt sich bei eigentlich allen
bei meinen Eltern und ich danke meinem
Vater Fernando Otero dem besten Vater
der Welt
[Musik]
ein gemischter Film Jahrgang haben vor
der Preisverleihung nicht wenige gesagt
aber dass das Kino zurück in den großen
Sälen ist hat nicht nur heute Abend alle
hier gefreut
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 5 12 23 26 33 48 Superzahl 4 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr geht noch
der Blick auf die Wetteraussichten im
Norden und Westen scheint morgen oft die
Sonne sonst überwiegen die Wolken und es
gibt einzelne Schneeschauer am
Erzgebirge und an den Alpen kann es auch
länger schneien bei einem eisigen
Nordostwind werden minus zwei bis plus 6
Grad erreicht am Montag gibt es im
Südosten noch letzte Schneeschauer sonst
bleibt es in den nächsten Tagen trocken
und die Sonne scheint häufig es wird
wieder etwas wärmer am Mittwoch zwei bis
zehn Grad
und das war es von uns wir gucken jetzt
das Sportstudio mit Sebastian Kehl
Sportdirektor vom BVB und die nächsten
Nachrichten gibt es hier gegen 0.55 Uhr
heute Express mit Ralf stepanski machen
sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind bis
morgen tschüss
[Musik]